um
lining up there's i think turkey's
president erdogan who has broken this
agreement for
russia and ukraine to sign there will be
actually separate agreements to get
grain moving it's been held up for
months since while the war has been
taking place over the past five months
the foreign office earlier said the
agreement must not only be agreed but
also implemented we have worked closely
with the un turkey ukraine and our g7
and g20 partners to unblock the grain
that putin has deliberately used to
weaponize food those are words from the
foreign office here some 22 million tons
of grain is stuck
around the black sea and will hopefully
move but as we were hearing from
chris elliott a few minutes ago it might
be at least two weeks before anything
that starts being moved let's just have
a listen and see if
there is
translation
russia and ukraine
witnessed by
turkey and the united nations welcome to
the signature ceremony
i would like to invite his excellency
u.s secretary general antonio guterres
for his remarks
your excellency president erdogan
excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
today
there is a beacon
on the black sea
a beacon of hope
a beacon of possibility
a beacon of relief
in a world that needs it more than ever
i want to recognize and thank all those
who helped make it happen
to our hosts president erdogan and the
government of turkey
your facilitation and persistence have
been essential
through every step of this process
shock to secure the rim
thank you very much
to the representations of the russian
federation and ukraine
[Music]
you have overcome obstacles and put
aside differences to pave the way for an
initiative that will serve the common
interests of all
promoting welfare of humanity
has been the driving force of these
talks
the question has not been what is good
for one side or the other
the focus has been on what matters most
for the people of our world
and let there be no doubt this is an
agreement for the world
it will bring relief for developing
countries on the edge of bankruptcy and
the most vulnerable people on the edge
of famine
and it will help sterilize global food
prices which were already at record
levels even before the war
through nightmare for developing
countries
specifically the initiative we just
signed opens a pass
for significant volumes of commercial
food exports from three key ukrainian
pores in the black sea
odessa chebonorsk and useni
the shipment of grain and foodstocks
into world markets will help bridge the
global food supply gap and reduce
pressure on high prices
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
this agreement did not come easy
since the war started i've been
highlighting that there is no solution
to the global food crisis without
ensuring full global access to ukraine's
food products and russian food and
fertilizers
today we took important steps to achieve
this objective
but it has been a long road
in april
after being received by president
erdogan
i met with president putin and president
zielinski to propose a plan for
solutions
and we have been working every day since
it took immense efforts and commitment
by all sides and weeks of
around-the-clock negotiations
the commitment and dedication are even
more vital today
this initiative must be fully
implemented because the world so
desperately needs it to tackle the
global food crisis
we count on the government of turkey to
maintain its critical role going forward
and i may hear to pledge the full
commitment of the united nations
will remain closely involved in working
for the agreement's success
we are ramping up efforts to ensure the
u.n is positioned to deliver on its
commitments
i'm grateful for the work of the two u.n
task forces that developed a parallel
coherent and coordinated approach
one led by martin griffiths and the
secretary general for humanitarian
affairs
and including the international maritime
organization
focused on the shipment of ukrainian
grains through the black sea
today we are announcing the
establishment of a joint coordination
center to monitor implementation of the
black sea initiatives
the other task force led by rebecca
greenspan secretary general of hong kong
centered on facilitating the unimpeded
access to food and fertilizers
originating in the russian federation to
global markets
and it also resulted in an agreement
i urge all sides to spare no efforts to
implement their commitments
we must also spare no effort for peace
this is an unprecedented agreement
between two parties engaged in bloody
conflict
but that conflict continues
and people are dying every day
and fighting is raging every day
the beacon of hope on the black sea is
shining bright today
thanks to the collective efforts of so
many in this trying and turbulent times
for the region and all globe
let that beacon guide the way towards
easing human suffering and securing
peace thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much excellency secretary
general
for his address
[Applause]
we held on
the 29th of march which constituted an
important turning point in the
negotiation process
i'm very pleased
to welcome you our esteemed friends
back in istanbul on another historic day
we are proud to be instrumental
in an initiative that will play a major
role in solving the global food crisis
that has been on the world's agenda for
a long time with the text
agreed upon today
um from africa to the middle east from
america to asia
we will contribute together to
preventing the danger of hunger that
billions face from all over the world
[Music]
ensuring world security of supply in
agricultural and food staff is important
in many aspects
with this step taken possible additional
soaring prices caused by the loss of
field to be caused by a current heatwave
and drought will be
prevented we are also helping with
controlling food inflation which has
become a global problem of course we did
not get to this point all of a sudden
we have carried out an intensive and
arduous process with the ukrainian and
russian authorities and the united
nations authorities for the
shipment
of the grain waiting in ukrainian silos
through the black sea we have been in
constant contact with our ukrainian and
russian counterparts throughout the
whole process
we have held extensive consultations to
address expectations and allied the
concerns of both countries regarding
this sensitive process
the ministers of foreign affairs have
made great
efforts
the contributions
of the secretary general of the united
nations his excellency teresh and his
team
contributed
to the plan the first draft of which was
prepared by them and that's very
commendable i would like to take this
opportunity to thank his excellency
president zielinski and his excellency
president putin for their leadership
with the vessel traffic that will start
in the coming days we will offer a new
airwave for breathing from the black sea
to many countries worldwide
at the port of destination consensus has
been reached upon all processes
the execution and supervision of this
extremely important plan will be carried
out by the joint coordination center to
be established in istanbul
the support of the international
community is without doubt of great
importance in the successful
implementation of the plan
distinguished friends about four months
ago
again in istanbul
[Music]
negotiations were held between ukraine
and russia and we made progress back
then
and this raised hopes that the war would
end unfortunately the developments that
took place after that meeting fueled the
conflicts
we have been saying from the very
beginning that there will be no winner
in this war
that not only the parties but the whole
world will suffer losses
the conflicts that have been going on
without interruption for about five
months and their global effects
unfortunately confirm this prediction
as it drags on to silence the guns
we have more economic costs and also
more human losses
the war
not only
adversely affects the parties and the
countries in the region but the whole of
humanity
including those in the most remote
corner of the world however we also
believe that this trend is not destined
we want these conflicts which cost lives
of innocents to end as soon as possible
we all know that there will be no losers
of a just peace
this
joint step we're taking today in
istanbul uh together with russia and
ukraine
will be a new turning point that will
revive the hopes for peace this is my
sincere hope
whatever direction the developments on
the field would take the war will
finally end at the negotiating table
this friendly and peaceful atmosphere
that we have established
[Music]
will be to the benefit of the whole
humanity and this will uh transform into
steps aimed at ending the war
we will continue to act with the
awareness of the responsibility our
understanding of civilization imposes on
us
we will continue to fulfill the
requirements of being neighbors until
peace prevails in our region may god
help us all
as i end my words with these thoughts i
would like to thank you again thank you
all
for your efforts
[Music]
i hope that the deal
that will be signed today will be
instrumental for the good of our
countries and all humanity
i also would like to
express my gratitude
personally and on behalf of my people
to everyone who has contributed to the
process to come to this day and i agree
to you again with this respect we would
like to thank his excellency president
erdogan for his remarks
well you've heard words there from
turkey's president richard
erdogan proceeded by the u.n secretary
general antonio guterres let's just stay
on these pictures now see if they're uh
this agreement is due to be signed uh
now they
are there it was supposed to have
happened what about 45
48 minutes ago these things are often
delayed aren't they but let me bring you
some words what uh the un secretary
general had to say a beacon of hope
and relief he talked about
on
possibility too on the black sea the
black sea beacon of hope he said was
shining bright he praised the
determination and persistence of turkey
to broker and indeed secure this deal
which is about to be signed now
um there's no solution he said to the
world's food shortage without full
access to ukrainian grain and russian
food and fertilizer let's
have a look now at what's going on there
and the books they're
going to be assigning
and you can see
there is the un secretary general
russia's defense minister sergey shoigu
is their
ukrainian infrastructure minister to as
well as turkey's president and the man
you're looking at
in the his orange thai there um that is
the un secretary general
uh the un and turkey brokering this
historic uh agreement to allow
or certainly designed to allow 22
millions of grain and other agricultural
products through
black sea ports stuck for so many months
because of
the war
so let's just
sit on these pictures just for a moment
there as we do
so some significant words from the un
secretary general and turkey's president
speaking their dignitaries from russia
and ukraine let's bring in alex rossi so
we've been waiting for it haven't we
this agreement to be signed for around
50 minutes alex it
that is now
happening as we've heard some words from
the un secretary general and some praise
for turkey
yeah i mean it is um whichever way you
look at it it is an extraordinary piece
of diplomacy remember that this
agreement that's been broken is
happening at a time when ukraine and
russia are locked in a
profoundly bitter fratricidal war that
is still raging across the country so
to see um two ministers from the
respective countries sitting down albeit
separated by a fairly long table is
really something of an achievement now
it's taken to get this far nearly three
months of negotiations as you can
imagine there isn't much trust there's a
great deal of suspicion on both sides of
each other's
motives but at the end
the agreement has been signed now the
goal in all of this is of course it's
not about ending the war that is a i
think a long way
off but it is about re-integrating
the ukrainian food economy back into
global markets now something like 22
million tons
of grain is currently trapped in silos
in ukrainian ports primarily the
ukrainian port city of odessa
and it can't can't get out because of a
naval blockade that russia has put in
place since it launched its invasion on
the 24th of february now this agreement
is fairly is very focused but what it
should mean in time and according to
senior un officials it could be as soon
as
ten days perhaps two weeks when we see
the first ships leaving with grain but
it should me should mean eventually and
to get fully working it perhaps might
take a month because it is a big
logistical challenge but you could see
something like five million metric tons
of grain leaving ukrainian ports heading
through the black sea
and uh into turkish waters through the
bottom of us where it will be
distributed around the world
particularly to countries in the global
south which are really facing
inflationary pressure as a result of the
cost of living crisis and the specter of
hunger and famine is becoming more and
more real every day now according to the
world food programme something like 47
million people are facing acute hunger
as a direct
consequence of this conflict and 71
million people according to the wfp are
being plunged into poverty as a direct
consequence of this
conflict so the urgency
with which this agreement now needs to
be implemented is extremely great now it
is a it is a day of hope it is a day of
optimism you heard the secretary general
antonio gutierrez
speaking there talking about a beacon of
hope on the black sea
um
but there are caveats in all of this
as i was saying earlier trust is a in
very short supply and it could be that
even though there is inc now on this
agreement that it could break down very
easily it's called the black sea
initiative but perhaps the best way of
looking at it is really as a ceasefire
at sea
now the way the deal will work is it's
going to be
closely monitored by all all sides in
this the ukrainians the russians the
turks and also officials from the united
nations there'll be a a joint
coordination center set up in istanbul
which will monitor
the ships leaving ukrainian ports but
crucially and this was a sticking point
uh in the negotiations particularly for
moscow there will be physical
inspections of ships heading back um to
ukrainian ports to make sure that there
won't be any
weapons on board those those ships that
ukraine could use to prosecute um the
war so that that's kind of where we are
at it's but of course as i was saying it
could break down but i think it's fair
to say that this is you know this is a
big moment
and it is a moment of hope
we'll certainly uh see what happens
won't we alex thank you very much indeed
for being with us for the last hours
we've watched a moment of history
haven't we in istanbul there this
historic agreement to certainly try to
get millions of tons of grain moving
from ukraine
uh more reaction to that to come during
the course of the afternoon
in the meantime i want to bring some
breaking news the uk government has
responded to the legal action launched
by the european union over the northern
ireland protocol saying a legal dispute
is in nobody's interest the eu i was
telling you a short time ago has accused
the government of failing to comply with
significant parts of northern ireland's
post-brexit trade rules well the
heightening of tensions comes after the
controversial northern ireland protocol
bill cleared the house of commons
this is not about us saying there's a
problem with this part of the bill or
problem with that part of the bill
that's not the point the point is we
have an international agreement signed
and ratified by both sides there should
be no uk bill currently going through
parliament
we are supposed to be implementing this
protocol together
and that's why
we believe that the simple fact that a
law has been introduced in order to
unilaterally change the way the protocol
works um is inappropriate and is linked
to the infringement that we have
presented today
let's get the thoughts of our political
correspondent mari aurora so the eu
murray flexes its muscle
the uk responds what happens next
well the issue with this now is it
really does feed in quite heavily to the
tory leadership campaign we know at the
moment boris johnson is technically
still prime minister but we won't be
there for much longer and these
infringement procedures are going to be
a thorn in the side of both liz truss
and rishi sunak while they try and
essentially sell themselves as hard
brexiteers and the best brexit candidate
the issue there is ironically liz truss
is the kind of brexiteer favorite
despite originally being a remainer and